intuition pumps are sometimes called
thought experiments more often they're
called thought experiments but they're
not really formal arguments typically
their stories their little fables in
fact I think they're similar to Aesop's
fables in that they are supposed to have
a moral they're supposed to teach us
something and what they do is they lead
the audience to an intuition a
conclusion where you sort of pound your
fist on the table and you say oh yeah
it's got to be that way doesn't it and
if if it achieves that then it's it's
pumped the intuition that was designed
to pump these are persuasion machines
little persuasion machines that
philosophers have been using for several
thousand years I think that intuition
pumps are particularly valuable when
there's confusion about just what the
right questions are and and what the
right what what matters what matters to
answer the question I think we're all
pretty good at using examples to to
think about things and intuition pumps
are usually rather vivid examples that
are some which you're supposed to draw a
very general moral and they come up in
many walks of life any time you're
puzzled or confused about what to do
next or whether something's true or
false you might cast about for an
intuition pump that could help you when
I first coined the term intuition pump
it's when Doug Hofstadter and I were
working on the mind's eye which has lots
of intuition pumps lots of thought
experiments in it and Doug came up with
the great metaphor he said what you want
to do with any of these intuition pumps
is twiddle all the knobs turn the knobs
see what makes it work now though this
is actually something that we're
familiar with from other parts of our
lives if there's a gadget and you want
to know what it does turn the knobs see
what happens you see what the moving
parts do so I encourage everybody to not
not just to take an intuition pump as
its handed to them but look at the
moving part see see what makes it tick
try to figure out what if I adjust this
well it's still pump the same intuition
well it's still you
feel the same putative conclusion or
will the whole thing fall apart and it's
interesting to see that a lot of times
philosophers will make an intuition pump
which seems to do great work until you
start turning the knobs and then you
realize that it actually depends on your
not thinking clearly about some aspect
of the problem then you've exposed it as
as not a good intuition pump but as
actually a negative one
I call them boom crutches because they
explode in your face